prima
si scaduto nel centro del buco della
ciambella
motore è bello io voglio questa rosa da
fermo è successo qualcosa di strano c'è
un mix tra me e questo personaggio
da oggi dovremo scappare dal fuoco
cattivo luca comodo
stanno aspettando di qt arti vedi dopo
il mandarino ti vuole spiaccicare poi
cuocere in forno è trasformato
in un biscotto
kg distante vi vado a prendere il cibo
carla non hai capito lui vuole mangiare
noi è
stato un bel mi piace iniziamo
l'avete sentita la voce per cui è stato
però qui siamo a niente perché io sono
pelata che succede salve sono un essere
operata e e trasparenze tv o dei vestiti
strani
perché ogni volta che quando si ha una
nuvoletta per questo reggiana va beh
niente io devo rimanere così grande
gioco lo capisco perché hai di rifarci
il ragazzo che dice o no il tubo si è
rotto e la salsa piccante e sul
pavimento
cliccate
ecco parlava di irritare volevo giusto
dire che questa sembra la mano in salsa
piccante secondo ha speso lamento di
vita è anche io quindi siamo 2 a 1 ha
detto che non farti distrarre dal cibo
secondo me vitale questo script room non
andrà molto bene perché si fa ad entrare
la cibo infatti non riesco neanche a
saltare sui tavolini paga zardini
sfracello si è fatta più che mai e
perché andiamo rimane gentile 6 cucina
perché non si può passare cugina la
salsa piccante
sul tavolo provato a stare sopra la
salsa piccante perché c'è la salsa di
counter sul tavolo nord beh qualcuno
l'avrà mangiata
ecco il cuoco
dobbiamo saltare quando non ci sono le
bollicine vediamo dopo giorno su 47
esclusivamente labriola devi guardare
dall'alto per riuscire a saltare
gli avanzi
giallo 64
prima per i commenti chi vincerà secondo
voi e cioè chi arriverà per primo a
prendere il badge
penale questo chiudendo lo spettacolo
dite che sfocia ricordi volta bellissima
questa cucina gigante
presta di su quelle scale
ciao io sono ancora pelata con un
artista degli occhi ma non possono delle
uova invece sono degli occhi
mentre nel frigo e prova a saltare gli
ostacoli che dobbiamo aspettare cielo
pizzo di gloria della pizza no party
distrarre dal cibo detto la pizza io
adoro le skate room in cui si sono le
coste i giganti e mettiamo in miniatura
che bello ma un frigo gigante posso fare
niente potrebbe essere cancellati
e guerra che sentiamo inizio però c'ha
degli occhi e dei tentacoli usciamo
fossero delle cipolle caramellate due
sono agli usi più tavoli e quindi queste
foto è decisamente un po martorano
eccoci ravot e tranne tra cui cucinerà
noi no lì c'è un patto sul cioccolato
non è che le coperte mentre leggeva
tutto daccapo adesso vitale rimarrebbe a
per un bel po diversi e chiude temi del
frigorifero tanto si sta fresco c'è
anche da mangiare per questo è vero che
x tutto
io non mi muovo da faccia
i commenti quanto caldo fa da voi da noi
qua sud sui 38 grassi sbaccanti
ronaldo
voglio
fretta si
decreta tutela campi sono tantissimo per
raggiungere vitale devo prendere il
belgio priva di lui però l'idea perché
non iniziamo a scommettere qualcosa per
chi arriva a prendere il primo il badge
quindi se arrivo a prendere prima io il
badge bici
cucinarmi o
regalarmi un'amica
questo vuol dire che facendo però fanno
per me e se vinco io cosa se dici tu
devi decidere tutto
[Applauso]
ma quindi non mi fa stare di qua
non era di là quindi non ha ricordi
questo di saltare dalla parte del manico
no no no per ora sono già passato avanti
state 6 solita
perché continua progettarvi ok almeno
passato questa parte però partiamo
dall altra parte dalla parte della
laguna via
da lì trova
praticamente dice non quanti bollire o
no se ne sta cucinando
qualcosa è stato fatto dimostra di
immortale perché vede quindi dobbiamo
saltare sulla carota penso mi sembra
quello che sembra buono perché forse sta
facendo il sugo pomodori carobbi
controllare
[Musica]
quei teschi non penso sia molto buono e
poi manca la cipolla abbiamo dal fuoco
qui domani lì dei lunapop e lì con la
parola rica che vuole
approcciarsi si canta ma devo aspettare
che passi il fuoco ed i progetti anch'io
sono già avanti sia via via via allora
quale prendiamo vediamo quale strada
prendiamo quinto al mare
riusciti a sorpassare il fuoco 0 era un
loro nome lo ritroveremo io dico verde
[Musica]
verde troviamo rosso
rosso godiamo il trucchetto non ha
iniziato provato e non è un verde
e via rosso blù e poi che sarà verde no
è verde ha mutato il cibo non lavorativo
mai fatto questo è concluso invece di
lavoro è piatto
e ha scritto un pezzo
di roma verranno stato giudicato come
postino non abbisognano scappata dalla
bambino ma che bello stiamo nuotando e
questo vuol dire che se non sono avanti
dove siamo finiti adesso mi sono gettato
non sono quello o no i tubi si sono
rotte
[Musica]
siamo di nuovo nelle foglie
delle teen gruppo capitiamo sempre nelle
fogne o nello stomaco di qualcuno
dici poco ci mangiano non riusciva con
la parte di quello che vuole fare
larrivey e cucinate non è visto con le
padelle giganti apposta per noi ci sono
ci sono dei tubi che stanno colando fa
dietro e con l'anno delle sostanze verdi
anche la vita ei tubi sono sono rotti
ecc dell'acqua tossica quindi siete voi
fate già parte della sua family
se non fate anche una parte della storia
stemmi nichi basta iscrivervi al canale
cliccare nella scampanellii redassero un
bel mi piace la sera ma c'è ancora il
mio libro a scuola di misteri non potete
in un nono prendetelo prendere la sua
parte della style spegne lo trovate su
ma la madonna è
ok vitale via su pranzo non va per
niente bene questa cosa l'ho già qual è
la forza giusta io ei suoi dei briganti
dai diktat agi
scherzo e cantate siglata un'ora del
sole sarà la volta giusta tu sei ancora
vivo quindi sarà questo lo fanno parte i
morti ci sono e tu sembravano nel gioco
vi ricordate poi di nuovo a scegliere la
pornostar e yahoo sì mi ricordo era
bellissimo siamo ancora vivi non ci
posso credere
sì grazie a me che sto facendo strada
vediamo cosa dice o no i tubi si sono
rotti e la l'acqua ha coperto tutto il
pavimento ma si deve andare nelle parti
pulite ciao militare continua strano
eh ma quindi non hai detto se vinci tu
che cosa vuoi invece per la scommessa io
voglio mangiare tantissimo ma quello fi
già
di più
ceduto velocità
tieni di più
avanti
si sbaglia la giusta vai avanti
ma perché i fanti fuori dalla barca e
riproviamo ok adesso si entra ma che
scappa non ti sei anche se vere e
proprio perché non quadra allora non si
sedere rimane in piedi
vai così
velocità
[Musica]
è stato bellissimo questa giro in barca
per di più più diamanti su questo tipo
ma sulla città lo sappiamo ma non ci
credo è andato man chiarita
siamo fuori dal ristorante
ferroso e pavimento partiamo
ciao
alberto
tesi ha fatto la strada della città devo
vincere io devo avere quella piccola
nata una vitale
la città è molto trafficata cerca di non
farti spiaccicare dalle macchine culo
sul proprio ci cascate stato prima cosa
per musica v adesso ci divertiamo con la
supervelocità io ho sempre scritto tocca
la linea e salta sopra i pezzi di strada
rotti
abbiamo
abbassato devo vincere quella vita
per portarmi fortuna così potrò
che posso partiamo
666 qual è il trucco per la
supervelocità andare piano
e no può darsi una brutta notizia
sei stato mangiato dal cuoco
ma ecco la bocca tempo avevo detto che
ci avrebbe mangiato vedremo circolare
una donna in e anzi questa volta ci ha
mangiato allora qui il nostro amico dice
di andare attraverso lo stomaco e
cioè della povera nello stomaco di
questo papa quarto mangia questo vuoto
voglio più e poi non ma vi è anche come
pensa ad un pezzo di torta p 0
una lattina soprattutto
[Musica]
ricaduto nel centro del buco della
ciambella
ok siamo in volta la giusta risplende la
pista che avvicinò
evitando così bene
e dobbiamo attraversare la sua sfida
torna ok vediamo vitale se cade ancora
nei loro la piccola gerbella e sul tocco
di
cadere esattamente nel buco della
ciambella tira quasi stabile ecco mi
attendo ora siamo nella fino ad ora
allora penso che dobbiamo scegliere fa
stare qua no eh sì però sono caduto che
sono in vantaggio apprezza o
cariche morire la porta giusta credo sia
questa quelle chiare devi prendere mi sa
che diavolo è già stai non è stato
difficile e soprattutto sono infatti
sono il vantaggio tv anzi
no manca pochissimo un uomo quella parte
di scola parte
infatti è che mi dice dobbiamo davvero
fare questo ma poi si fa
bisogna saltare e non so come fu di
[Musica]
voglio la pizza con i lunghi e carciofi
e le zucchine ma perché lo farò ma io
non metto le unità a città cosa è
tuttavia ma siccome questi promessa da
basile e soprattutto perché ti ho fatto
venire un sacco di fame in acqua allora
abbiamo non in store bike proviamo ci
siamo non ho idea di dove siamo nè come
funzioni questo gioco balla stupri
che
ho preso
cifra fissa mente questo gioco consiste
nel scappare da sonic si stai attenta
perché ce n'è anche un altro pozzo
grassani che dovrebbe essere velocissimo
ma quel sonic camminava molto lenta
andatura ma siamo più veloci troy come
preside eco sonic e io provo a venire
qua se questo non è sonic mai un
giocatore ma anche questo nero
un aiuto ma c'è un altro storico con
fuori quindi pensi non ce ne sono quelli
italiani
mi stai seguendo come avete fatto voi a
trasformarli in sonic
io sono qui ma
così non riesce a passare
e non c'è in altri quindi di restare un
po attenta più tempo sopravviviamo più
punti facciamo finito allora qui ci sono
delle volte in vestiti 61 auto dina di
sony qua c'è uno scivolone di qualcuno
sta volando con il tappeto
gli assi un garage auto vediamo se
diciamo a prendere un'auto davvero
fresca panasonic ha come hai fatto ad
andare lì dove c'è sonico da vicino alla
porta e uno sonica lei mi è successo
qualcosa che è successo o tipo le ali da
fumo
devo assolutamente fede
spiace
che è ben 800
di qua
non
per niente bene ai dopo l'eco tre anni
da pochi mia sfracellato dai portoni
giro in macchina
trasformato in corsa per lo so ho
trovato queste armi così ei finora
abbiamo sopra messo
come possiamo dare al mio boh non lo so
lo shopping center dove vi pochi ho
un'idea niente quando mi ha visto da
tali c'è un ristorante ma non mi sembra
proprio ristorante lo pensano
che cosa è questa una scala per fallire
attenta sta arrivando sono i funerali
bonanni meglio prendere quello che sto
per voi è capitato forze sky calcio 8
accaduto beh saliamo questo pre speriamo
che cosa ci facciamo prendere un po la
macchina
[Musica]
e successo qualcosa di strano c'è un mix
tra me e questo personaggio molto bene
wow vanno velocissimi
oberate più carina sono sonic femmina
rosa che non mi ricordo come si chiama
questo personaggio
da questo personaggio giallo ok vediamo
quanto tempo riesce a sopravvivere con
il quale come vi abbiamo i poteri vedi
che adesso corriamo più veloci perché io
non vado più veloce per odom avere
qualche potere no
[Musica]
volevo dire macchina ci sono già
distratto sonic grazie devo andare
subito anche in macchina perché sono
troppo network sarebbe stato tina allora
andò a prendere io sono quello giallo
macchina bianca con la ecco che ti vedo
io non ci credo sì sono stati quando più
toni dvd investo tranquilla tanto c'è
questa materia ma che mi hanno rubato la
macchina era questa è la festa la tua
macchina
ci sono giusto anche quello nero è
quello blu che io sono super veloce 6
perché tu hai preso il costume da sonic
solo che è però ce l'avevo questo già
volumi che sonic anno quando l'amico di
sonico questo marmellata anche lui sa
quale macchine sono finite dove ce n'è
qualcuna qui la novità ricattata via
questa nostra vita che sta facendo
disastri con
un'idea facciamo una gara in macchina
vediamo chi è più veloce ma se io sto
cercando di prenderla venduti quasi
ancora beh allora aspetta simili mentre
proprio a piano d'accio facendo manovra
ma dove sei ha dato il suo ok allora cv
o via
dobbiamo raggiungere la fine ma finger
proporsi anzi dobbiamo proprio buttarsi
giù chi si butta ottima kikanovic
32 ora
ciao ho vinto quindi adesso mi devi fare
la pizza anche tu a me non è vita non ti
sei ancora buttato però su tavola allora
quando arrivi alla fine e praticamente
tissone sceniche e mi convinceva a capo
il costume e la macchina quindi non lo
fare anche la macchina si rendiamo la
macchina e speriamo che nessuno si mette
davanti a bloccare haimè stoffa c'è
questo giocatore che si mette per prima
ma non vuole che guido la macchina vi
sta dando fastidio
e così ti vedo ok a moser che eravate
pare è colpa di questo giocatore store è
più vita chiedono massimo sono riusciti
a quel giocatore è entrato in macchina
così forse mi lascerà in pace allora io
vado a cambiare tutina intanto ok
scappiamo il più velocemente possibile
da quel giocatore
ma dopo e ora buttiamoci anche nuove
mappe nel frigo quadro ridiamo
si no
va beh
ve lo chiedo a tributare a messina
siamo onesti rubando basilesi nei
commenti che gioco vi è piaciuto di più
il primo il secondo allora vi lasciamo
papa allora se l'idea su cui cliccare
prevedere altri video cliccate su quella
preferita
ciao